hey guys guess what oh my goodness you
probably already know judging by the
title of this video and the thumbnail
that apple is holding an event on march
8th at 10 a.m pacific so obviously i was
super excited to see that this was
announced and i just kind of wanted to
like take a little peek see what some of
the rumors are like what can we expect i
mean i kind of have an idea because i'm
basically looking at the website right
now that has some rumors thank you mac
rumors always my go-to
so before we get into the rumors a huge
thank you to skull candy for sponsoring
today's video these are the new skull
candy grind fuel true wireless earbuds
these are starting at 99.99
let's open them up
so these will give you up to 40 hours of
battery life and they also have this
really cool wireless charging case but
if you decide to plug these in with usbc
you can get a rapid charge so 10 minutes
of charge time will give you two hours
of battery these are also ip55 sweat and
water resistant they have premium audio
quality and they have skull iq smart
features for hands-free voice commands
you can change the tracks adjust the
volume and even launch spotify these
work with both android and ios they have
over-the-air updates with the skullcandy
app you can tune your audio experience
by taking a real-time audio test to
create a personal sound profile for
optimized audio levels okay this is
pretty cool you can even set up a take a
photo in the skull iq feature
open my camera after my oh my god i can
use it as a remote okay we're gonna set
the
left earbud so when i press it three
times it's gonna take a photo
okay that's pretty awesome one of the
things that i really love is these have
a built-in tile tracker so if you happen
to misplace an earbud you can actually
ring it inside of the tile app to help
you find it do you hear that they're
making little sounds i'm pinging them
with the tile app let's see what these
sound like hey skull candy play it also
has the stay wear mode okay my music is
very loud right now i'm gonna turn this
on so that i can actually hear my
surroundings
there we go it kind of amplifies the
sounds around me so that i can hear
things that are happening i will put a
link in the description if you guys want
to find out more information about the
skull candy grind fuel true wireless
earbuds they are available online and
select retailers now let's jump into the
rumors oh hi uh welcome back thank you
skullcandy for sponsoring this video
much appreciated if you guys don't know
like basically brand integrations are
how i kind of fund this channel so
without them i would be begging you guys
to buy merch and for donations and
here's the great news i don't have to do
that because incredible brands have been
so supportive of my channel and i am so
grateful and thank you guys so much for
watching them but now we're going to get
into the rumors so here on mac rumors i
love you guys you're incredible they're
talking about what we can expect from
the apple's upcoming 2022 iphone se so
saying that this should be coming out
within a matter of weeks which is
actually quite accurate because this was
february 4th they're saying that the
price would be around the 399 price
point not expecting any new big design
changes so here's what the current
iphone se looks like and the thing that
i love so much about the se is the fact
that it still has the fingerprint
scanner i love being able to unlock my
iphone with my apple watch which i
actually i didn't charge this morning so
it's currently on the charger right now
which i'm i feel so naked without it i
love my apple watch the freaking touch
id is just like the best thing in the
world and i hope i'm still fingers
crossed that they decide to put touch id
in the new iphone 14 like put it in the
power button that would just be the
perfect spot for it although iphone se
touch id for people who just need that
for whatever reason and if this is
something that you do want or need
hopefully they don't take it away from
the iphone se i don't think that they
will so the current models of the iphone
se come in the black the white and the
product red they're assuming that there
may be similar colors but i'm hoping for
some some new spicy colors like let's
spice it up so saying that all other
phones at this point have transitioned
to face id and there's rumors that the
future versions of the low-cost iphone
will do the same which i feel like could
possibly be an option but if you do have
touch id that's one of the big reasons
that you would be also getting the
iphone se well wireless charging but no
magsafe 5g speeds gotta have it an
updated processor updated battery life
cameras the iphone se is expected to
feature an updated camera so it could
adopt the latest wide-angle camera from
the iphone 13. they don't know specifics
at this time but camera improvements are
planned that's definitely a given with
any device it's like all right we're
going to improve the battery life we're
going to improve the camera i mean
hopefully the screen will be a little
bit better i mean those are just things
that like if those basic needs aren't
met in an upgrade for a phone then i
think something's wrong then there's no
reason to upgrade it would make
absolutely no sense at all apple could
call the new iphone sc the iphone se 5g
yeah let's throw let's do that let's
toss in our 5g buzzwords we
love it
5g when it's actually readily available
one like ultra wide band and these
speeds that we have seen in test cases
are actually everywhere is going to be
life changing so next up in the rumors
we have the next gen ipad air saying
they're probably not going to be making
any huge design changes it's gonna get a
faster chip 5g connectivity and it could
also be updated with a new facetime
camera that supports center stage and i
have been using my ipad so much recently
over the past couple of months i've been
working on this little illustration
project and if you're wondering justine
why haven't you been posting youtube
videos it's because i have been drawing
on my ipad and it has been so fun it has
also been extremely therapeutic it's
just the most relaxing thing and i've
been having the best time like procreate
and my ipad like we're now best friends
i loved the previous versions of the
ipad air although i have been using my
ipad pro and that's been incredible just
because the amount of layers and kind of
processing power that i need for the
thing that i'm working on the ipad pro
has been so perfect but the ipad air is
also an incredible device and it can
definitely handle all of the things that
you would need to do with it and the
fact that it does have the touch id in
the power button is just shows us that
it's possible like the technology is
there just think about putting that in
everything like it's just great it just
works so seamless absolutely love it it
would be great if they did integrate
center stage into the ipad air because
that feature is really cool i've been
doing so many more face time calls over
the past couple of years so i definitely
love the fact that i can kind of set my
ipad down and just sort of walk around
and kind of be just like carrying on
about my day is pretty cool another
rumor we have is they're planning on
releasing a higher end version of the
mac mini with an overhauled design oh
new design
let's hear it the new mac mini will
replace the current intel mac mini
options and it could come at apple's
march event well guess what the event is
here also i absolutely love these
athletic greens not sponsored but if
they want to sponsor just dm me actually
so the final device rumored for march
8th is an updated version of the 13-inch
macbook pro which is said to be equipped
with an m2 chip oh my god are we already
at m2 now is this happening the
successor to the m1 chip the macbook pro
will look identical to the current 13
inch model and it'll be a lower end
version of the 14 and 16 inch microphone
oh my god okay so when the m1 first came
out the 13 inch macbook pro was so
incredibly revolutionary that i
basically ditched my 16 inch intel
macbook basically edited all of my
projects off of that 13-inch macbook for
an entire year and i even
was choosing it over my mac pro because
this m1 was so powerful and now at this
point we're like what two three years in
to kind of that transition period away
from intel apps drivers mac os monterey
like all of these things are slowly
starting to get updated because i'm not
gonna lie like those first few months
were pretty tough especially with a lot
of my plugins for final cuts my audio
interface stopped working and i there is
an update for that now so that's great
but i actually kind of ended up getting
a different set of speakers that i
really liked since i've been using the
macbook we're slowly on that trajectory
like everything that apple has been
talking about with their new silicon
chips and kind of that transition like
it's it's happening i know that people
who have been using the newest macbook
pros like we can attest to i guess
depending upon what you're doing but for
the scenarios that i am in and what i'm
working on god it's so perfect you
are perfect so the m2 chip will
apparently feature the same eight core
cpu as the m1 but speed and efficiency
improvements are expected like i said we
gotta have these upgrades if you're not
gonna have these types of upgrades
there's literally no reason to upgrade
okay so apple plans to stream this event
live on its website yes yes and yes
apple's march 8th peak performance event
features an animated ar logo oh my god i
love this that's another thing that i'm
really excited about that apple has kind
of slowly been i guess kind of pushing
for all of us to check out is augmented
reality and there's so much talk of the
metaverse and what does that even mean
like at some point it's just a buzzword
that people are throwing around like oh
yeah i'll still see in the metaverse
yeah okay metaverse metaverse metaverse
there's gonna be many metaverses like i
think that's the misconception of
everyone just thinks facebook kind of
coined that phrase metaverse and then
changed their name to meta they're not
gonna be the only ones that are doing a
metaverse i mean even right now like
looking at sort of the landscape of
these various different types of
metaverses there's so many out there
don't worry you're not missing out yet
ah yeah let's let's talk about it i
think you guys know what i'll be doing
on march 8th i look forward to seeing
your guys's thoughts if you want to chat
in the comments below feel free to do so
i will definitely be
actually maybe i should hang out on
discord because my sister and i do have
a discord i'll put a link in the
description if you want an invite to
check it out it is a very safe space and
we all have a lot of fun there it's
called same brain you also want to
follow me on twitter i will definitely
be live tweeting the event and of course
on instagram and here on youtube
subscribe hit the bell and i will see
you
very
very soon
can't wait
[Music]
you